take a look at alec mills obviously as
we've said
a few times through a no-hitter in his
last start twins are going to have to be
patient he's in the zone
less than he's actually out of the zone
he relies on aggressiveness of the
hitters he's got a slow curve ball
you got a change up two down nobody on
no score top of the first
rosario hammers one high and deep to
right field beckett goes deep it goes
and gone
any wasting little time homer's out to
the bleachers and right
his 12th home run one-nothing twins
during the opening inning yeah there
goes that base hit third batter right
incredible that will be no no-no
for mills tonight score a run last night
it took him
just three at bats to get on the board
here fastball elevated just
a little bit deposited over the wall and
right big mike has
picked up right where he left off last
year on fortune suspension and
but he was able to go in get his work
done and he's looked
mid-season for him you know since we've
seen him out there he's been a great
addition almost like a
trade deadline acquisition for this twin
staff so see if he's able to continue
that tonight
ryan's had a rough goal here in 2020
he's been hurt
finger injury wrist injury only two home
runs and the three one pitch has popped
up
shallow right in from right comes kepler
on the grass calls and catches in front
of his shoulder for out number two
here's david bodie runners at first and
third one to nothing minnesota second
inning two down a 2-1
home to bodhi
contreras is in hayward the third
he'll be held there it's a double for
bodhi and we're tied at one
despite having that bat in a few days
david bodie
delivers david bodies missed a couple of
ball games and now he comes through
right away in his first a b
there's just a fastball inside and this
is right in his wheelhouse and he smokes
this ball
down the third base line two down here
in the third and the batter anthony
rizzo in a one-to-one game
and the one-two pitch a fly ball deep
into right field on the track is kepler
and the wind's gonna push it back and
max has a play
and he's got it for route number three a
couple of well struck balls on both
sides tonight but the wind
is helping some teams out help the twins
out there
here's miguel about mcgill went down
swinging his first time up
fastball strike three called sayonara to
sano
two down here in the fourth inning and
the batter is max kepler
oh and now hayward will bat edward
singled his first time up
that is a base hit is on his way to
third
he's going to stay there i thought he
might keep going
uh you know the way he is so aggressive
and daring on the base pass
any club that plays the cubs are going
to talk about that and say hey make sure
in the outfield you're uber aggressive
come and get the ball and hustle it back
into the infield
two outs here's david bodie he already
has one
clutch hit in this game and here it is
ground ball this can be fielded by
polanco he'll get the force out
at second base so they threaten here
they get a couple of hits leave two
completed four here gonzales two for
eleven on this road trip
oh my mills makes the play second one
two what a play by alec mills
i think he caught that between his legs
between the legs
and the good feed to second base oh
we'll be seeing that over and over on
the highlight rails right there that was
a
kind of stick of glove out the ball
finds your glove but fortunate for the
twins ends up being a double play
and strike three right down broadway so
mills gives up the lead on base hitter
raced on a nice double play and
adrian's a strikeout seven night four
mills
so now little bass hit you got some
speed at second base
and here's rosario that ball drilled
into right field
cave will be sent home here's the throw
to the plane and he scores
rosario delivers an rbi single and the
twins are back in front
i'm not certain that he was looking
curveball right here but it sure looked
like it otherwise he just recognized it
really well and he's seeing the ball
already a home run in this game miguel
leads off this seventh inning
and the one-old pitch is swinging a
blast into left field and deep
back it goes deep it goes and on to
waveland avenue
cino clears the bleachers and left and
sends one on to wavelength
a long home run for the big guy his 13th
overall
and the twins now take a 3-1 lead here
in the seventh inning
453 feet left his bat at 115 miles an
hour
if you're new to distance you're new to
exit velocity
that was really hit far and really hit
hard
so marvin gets hit by a slider right on
his foot and he will take his base
painfully
and now that loads him up with nobody
out
and the 2-1 pitcher ground ball too
short played by baez comes home
and contreras cannot dig it out of the
ground kepler
slides and scores donaldson is safe at
first as the twins add a run now lead
4-1
and that'll probably be an error on baez
mitch garver at the plate
sharply hit into left field garver
delivers
one run will score two runs will score
and the pinch hitter
delivers a big pitch hit now it's up to
byron the eighth twin to bat
sharply hit and into center field of
base head
donaldson comes in from third base and
the twins get another run
producing two out hit and buckston now
is thrown out
at second base but the run counts it's a
five run in it
two down nobody on top of the ninth
inning twin seven
cubs one drive to right field
going back is hayward at the wall it's
gone
a home run for josh donaldson to the
opposite field
and the twins had one more now lead
eight to one and it's going to be billy
hamilton
and now the 1-1 a swing of the fly ball
into left-field routine
over to his right is wade he's got it
and the minnesota twins for the 14th
time in team history
will play post-season baseball